wasser auf gani med neue chance für
mission rosetta und trauriger rekord das
sind drei der fünf themen jetzt in link
zum top 50
wasser auf dem jupitermond gani med ist
einer der vier größten jupiter monde die
auch galileo monde genannt werden
forscher haben und hinweise darauf
gefunden dass unterganges oberfläche ein
flüssiger ozean plätschert und damit
zumindest die möglichkeit für
außerirdisches leben innerhalb unseres
sonnensystems bietet das wasser soll
sich unter einer riesigen eisschicht
verstecken und es besteht die
möglichkeit dass es dort mehr salz
wasser gibt als hier auf der erde die
hinweise gehen zurück auf das hubble
space telescope gani med ist außerdem
der einzige mond in unserem sonnensystem
mit einem eigenen magnetfeld deshalb
kann man auf manchen bildern von ihm
nicht erkennen die an unsere
polarlichter erinnern
neue chance für fiel ihr die
landeeinheit fiel ihr der mission
rosetta hat in dieser woche mehrere male
die möglichkeit aus dem standby-modus
aufzuwachen
die forscher hoffen auf ein
lebenszeichen im jetzigen modus kann das
minilabor nicht viel machen außer seinen
temperatur und das einfallende
sonnenlicht beobachten denn von diesen
beiden parametern hängt ab ob die
landeeinheit wieder erwacht wenn viel er
nämlich mehr als minus 45 grad celsius
warm wird und gleichzeitig von der sonne
mehr als 55 watt strom erhält dann wird
er seine forschungsarbeit auf dem
kometen tschurjumow gerasimenko wieder
aufnehmen es kann allerdings auch gut
sein dass dies bereits passiert ist wir
davon nichts wissen
denn um ein signal auf die erde zu
schicken benötigt viel eher noch mehr
sonnenenergie bis zum 20 märz wird die
raumsonde rosetta noch versuchen kommt
kaum kontakt mit der land einheit
aufzunehmen danach ist erstmal wieder
funkstille
zehntausende tote einem neuen bericht
der weltgesundheitsorganisation whu
zufolge erreicht die anzahl der ebola
opfer einen traurigen rekord mehr als
10.000 menschen sind bis heute in guinea
liberia und sierra leone am ebola virus
gestorben ob bericht haben sich seit
ende 2013 mehr als 24.000 menschen mit
dem erreger angesteckt allerdings lässt
die bhu auch hoffen so wurde in liberia
seit zehn tagen
keine neuerkrankungen gemeldet in
monrovia wurde sogar die offiziell
letzte ebola patienten entlassen und
auch in den nachbarländern gehen die
neuerkrankungen von ebola stark zurück
und dürfen trotzdem nicht nachlässig
werden so der experte florian westphal
der ebola ausbruch ende 2013 ist der
schlimmste seit der entdeckung des virus
vor über versichert der mann der niemals
schläft ein 89 jähriger mann aus
istanbul behauptet seit mehr als 55
jahren nicht mehr geschlafen zu haben
er habe 1960 einfach die fähigkeit
verloren einzuschlafen
bis jetzt konnten die ärzte in istanbul
auch noch nicht das gegenteil beweisen
bei untersuchungen schließen die ärzte
immer vor dem mysteriösen nicht schwer
verein experten sind jedoch der meinung
dass der mann sehr wohl schlafe und zwar
unter bewusst und über den tag verteilt
immer nur ein paar minuten so dass er
selber ist bewusst gar nicht merkt der
89-jährige findet seinen zustand
übrigens gar nicht schlecht er nutzt die
zusätzliche zeit nachts zum lesen von
büchern und lösen von kreuzworträtseln
welt bietet heute am 14
2015 ist offizieller welt peter who
denn in der amerikanischen schreibweise
des datums in der tat und monat
vertauscht werden stellt das datum die
ersten drei ziffern vom pedal wenn wir
jetzt noch das jahr 2015 zu einer 15
kürzen dann hat unser datum am
samstagmorgen um 9 uhr 26 minuten und 43
sekunden
die insgesamt ersten zehn ziffern von pi
dargestellt hat bewies tja das ist die
zahl mit der man cries berechnung und
danach 31 14
viele mathematiker und forscher feiern
den tag traditionell mit bei also kuchen
mit der bg geschrieben wer heute nicht
feiern kann oder es verpasst hat der
kann am 22 juli nochmal feiern den 22
durch 7 ist eine andere darstellungsform
von pi wenn er mehr zum thema ebola
wissen wollt dann klickt hier hin auf
das video
da wird so ziemlich alles erklärt
allerdings natürlich wie immer unten in
der video beschreibung zur kriegs vom
app für android und iphone geht's da
zum blog mit spannenden und
wissenschaftlichen artikeln und was
meint ihr soll man solche tage feiern
also den welttag wie feiert ihr den
vielleicht auch mit kuchen oder so oder
feiert er auch den welt handtuch tag
oder wie es der obmann der ist schreibt
ein diskutiertes und mit den kommentaren
schreibt es rein oder auch wenn er denkt
dass es nur quatsch ist einfach
diskutieren machen solche tagen
überhaupt sinn für die wissenschaft
vielleicht ein bisschen erinnern an das
was da interessant sein weil beschreibt
es also im rhein und ansonsten bist du
genau dann